i certainly have to drive fast to get to
my next destination
well i certainly have to drive fast to
get to my next destination
this video is a commentary about how
movies have kind of gone full circle
where older movies had like the kind of
shitty looking uh rear view projection
kind of thing you know it doesn't look
like they're driving and then at a
certain point cameras got smaller and
smaller so that they could fit inside of
a car and we could get really cool
car shots but now that it's become i
guess cheaper to like shoot with a green
screen behind a car um things just kind
of look shitty again and fake like
people aren't actually driving so um
i guess
the the point of this video is to
is to emphasize how
the effects while different techniques
it's kind of come full circle in terms
of shitty looking driving shots
not to you know
not to call out older movies for doing
that you know because you know sometimes
a stylistic effect can look cool you
know but but a lot of times it was just
it didn't look great
so um
that's
around yeah she loves